Probably just too flat there, guys.
Into the next grid.
That's it. Next grid. Next grid. Four and three.
Talk. Talk on the wing. Talk on the wing. Eyes up. Eyes up.
There you go, Ty.
That's it. You're in there, Marlon. Eyes up, Marlon. Talk to him. Talk to him, Marlon.
Nice, Joe.
Next group. Frank. Frank. Frank. Get in there, Frank.
Frank.
Nice, Tom. Way to get that ball off.
Next job now. Next job. Way to get that ball away, Dom.
Good idea. Good idea. Next row.
Nice. Next. Next. Four and three here.
Nice, Tyrus. That's it. That's it.
That's the idea, boys.
Go, Reb. Go, Reb. Go, Reb.
Get to your hands.
Nice. Well done. Well done.
That's it. That's it.
Go, go, go. Go, go, go, go, go.
Yes, Rob.
Yes, boys.
Talk to him, Joe. Talk to him, Joe.
You're in space, Joe. You're in space. That's it.
That's it. That's it. Defense. Defense. Defense. Defense.
Defense.
That's it, boys.
Yeah.
There you go, guys.
Defense. Tweet in here. Tweet in here.
Tweet in here.
Nice. Well done. Well done. You're in there. You're in there.
You're in there. Adv fries up. Adv fries up. Adv fries up.
Ad minha tenta. Adv my tenta. Adv tenta.
Avデ Pyro.
Av Hoch
Ad fem.
Ab commission.
A-d k.
Sev science mil.
All-in training.
One more time.
Alright.
Ladies and gentlemen.
11.